Douglas a difficult tournament for you
up to this point but finally you get
that breakthrough what an incredible
Victory congratulations tell us a bit
about your experience with this game but
also with the tournament as a whole oh
need so many blunders I'm hoping I
finally didn't Escape no
uh yeah I'm very fortunate to have won
and I
uh
I'm really happy it looked like a nice
game I haven't had time to go over it in
any detail yet
Alexi your wife who is also here with
you as your second she did say that you
had to dust off some rust off your
shoulders but now finally that you did
that you produced a masterpiece I have
to say and I want to go towards the end
this was the critical moment when he
found this move B4 very beautiful tell
us a bit about the story of this move
why this works and what were your
feelings when you found this move from
afar oh well I knew I had my thread of
Knight H7 and queen h8 check followed by
Queen f8 mate
but if I wait too long then he might be
able to consolidate and so uh
uh and he was at the moment threatening
to check me or or at least a very bad
check with the rookie one check I'd have
to which I would have to give up my
queen with Queen F1 to avoid me but um
so in order to uh gain time for my
intended Knight H7 I could play the
interference move before and like a
study situation right now he can defend
with Queen E5 because the Rook d8
everything is kind of yeah just uh
connecting very well for you yeah this
one Douglas congratulations uh big game
for you guys any questions for Douglas
yeah Douglas congratulations on a very
nice game uh we really liked in the
studio the sequence right F4 kind of
making the B2 Pawn
um poison and then Queen C1 and F5 was
that the moment when you started to feel
like you know you have the game in your
hands very comfortable at this moment or
did you still think uh you know that's a
fighting game
uh I thought that I had a uh good attack
at this point
um whether it was winning or not I I
couldn't say it this early for certain I
hoped it was
[Laughter]
it looked good to me and so I I went uh
for this uh exchange I
um I thought he might actually uh take
on F5 with the bishop after uh oh after
G takes uh F5 he takes F5 Bishop takes
F5 uh in which case I have uh moves such
as Knight D4 because the bishop has been
to the Knight and uh then uh rookie five
and uh I was considering G4 at this
point which looks strong to me at the
time why not yeah yeah no A3 I think is
the best but G4 looks very promising as
well beautiful yeah yeah sir very nice
game and spectacular finish
congratulations absolutely
and here are our results